una vez
[Música]
el 31 de mayo de 2001 como todos los
días
en esa época traje y corbata en esos
años en este país por el sector
corporativo usábamos traje corbata y
todo eso
subí a mi auto de 98
también la plata en esa época y buenos
partidos nuevamente por la ciudad por la
autopista llegué temprano a la oficina
como buen vendedor que soy ocho y media
de la mañana y algo ya no andaba bien
tenían
un dolor de cabeza
presta atención porque todos los días
en esos días tenía doctor de cabeza
empecé a trabajar y los malestares
empezaron a ser cada vez más grandes
malestar como estomacal madre o la
cabeza hacia el mediodía el dolor era
insostenible así que pido permiso a mi
jefe
lo que hice después no se lo recomiendo
a nadie me subí a mi auto y volvió los
60 km manejando
yo a mi casa somos la prepaga viene el
médico la revisa me dice el señor usted
tiene una arritmia lo tenemos que
internar inmediatamente
hasta la semana su vida corre peligro
bueno en esa época vivía a dos cuadras
del hospital español de la ciudad la
plata
así que a los 10 minutos estaban
internados en terapia intensiva todos
conectados con cables conectores
mangueras de 8 personas más que luchas
por su vida
y eso momento pensé que hice mal de que
no me di cuenta
qué pasó acá
qué nos pasa que vamos por la vida
siempre estar atención a las señales
entre otras cosas que nos dan nuestro
cuerpo
cómo es que seguimos en automático
siempre estaba atención a estas señales
cuando fue la última vez
que presta atención a estas señales
lo compraste con alguien
tenéis algún pariente amigo conocido por
estos temas
estuve dos días internado en terapia
intensiva después pasé al piso
y estuve 15 días
dedicado
con la línea la línea es cuando el
corazón se sale del mismo y la sensación
es que no sabe si estás vivo estás
muerto porque no sentís los latidos del
corazón
en ese momento
mi vida estaba afuera de
si me quedo muy claro pero muy claro que
tenía el campo de trabajo porque no
tenía la capacidad emocional para
soportar las presiones que ese trabajo
estaba
poniendo así que los pocos meses cambio
de trabajo
al día siguiente empiezo a dejar por la
región
tiene una reunión de negocios típicas de
negocios hotel señal con comida rica
bebidas y demás negocios con una
empresaria local entonces empiezo a
hablar de las cualidades de servicio y
que vas a tener esto vas a llegar a todo
el país y demás y esta mujer me dice
vimos cómo cultivar tu espíritu
seguí hablando no le escuché para nada
puedes entrar
es una pregunta
así que dije
me dice conoce
internamente eso estaba en llamas
a mil kilómetros de del negocio teniendo
que hacer una venta esta mujer que me
habla del espíritu bueno conclusión
segunda señal que no escuche
bien
estuvimos hablando una hora de y media
entonces ahora empezar a pensar en esto
así que ahora a partir de ese momento
empecé a prestar atención
pasa lo que conocemos como determinada
espiritual
cuando tenéis el despertar espiritual
las sensaciones wow me perdí todo esto
durante toda su acción estaba como
muerto si quiere saber todo ya y ahora
entonces lo que siguió en los próximos
años
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y ahí vienen por supuesto que la muerte
a la cabeza bien
impresionante el proceso no y como me di
cuenta que esto estaba en efecto en mí
porque son cosas espirituales y
materiales que tiene con las personas
las energías hubo mil 50
me di cuenta que es que nuevas pastillas
de jartúm analgésicos deje de tomar
cosas para el estómago de tumán cosas
tenía un dolor y ya no tuve una pastilla
y otra cosa importantísima especial
conocer a la gente abrir una gente con
sus historias conocer a mi compañero de
trabajo saber que tenían hijos hacer ese
tipo de cuestiones
está bastante enfocados minero de
trabajo y algo se estaba abriendo y
claro y otra cosa importantísima fue
la pregunta
qué fue lo que hice mal que se seguía
dando vuelta entonces empecé a estudiar
todo lo que tuviera que ver con
administración del tiempo y como todo lo
que tiene que ver con con esta vorágine
y demás imaginen una catarata que es
impresionante llena de agua además
cuando llegan al fondo que llega el de
más así que el fondo mi remanso para
este proceso fueron dos carreras
adicionales es el coaching ontológico y
las constelaciones familiares
y
también esta pregunta de que el sistema
de sistema
en el tiempo y para uno de los
principales referentes que se los
recomiendo es toda la vida stephen covey
donde aprendí a administrar por
prioridades
seguí hablando el tema
y
encontré lo siguiente que tenemos
nosotros
dormimos 7 horas
nos levantamos estamos una hora más o
menos donde vuelta otra hora para viajar
y luego darles el mejor de los casos
para trabajar otra hora para volver 10 a
3 19 20 horas sobre los 4
por suerte están los fines de semana
entonces el punto es qué hacemos con
esas pocas horas teniendo todo para una
sola actividad
empecemos por anunciar ponerse las
actividades y nosotros por lo general
desarrollamos una vida estándar es son
cinco la familia el trabajo la
recreación el desarrollo personal y la
comunidad
y que nos pasan estos dominios están
todo el tiempo compitiendo unos con
otros
levantando la mano para quien de ustedes
la familia es lo más importante
el trabajo
de esta racha personal
recreación amigo grupo de pertenencia
comodidad hacer algo por nosotros
bueno
todos son igualmente importantes pero
qué nos pasa como lo vivimos
internamente los vivimos como en
competencia
típico típica situación estoy con mi
familia estoy pensando de trabajo o me
voy a jugar los jueves a la noche con
mis amigos al fútbol
la mujer típica y le dice al marido che
todo bien con el tema
[Aplausos]
y qué nos pasa con todo eso los sufrimos
y lo vivimos internamente como como en
competencia
y nos duele una parte
entonces
cuál es la propuesta para ustedes hoy es
cambiar una sola palabra
y esa palabra de competencia porque
porque si es competencia cuantos
ganadores puede haber uno y siempre gana
uno a costa de los demás siempre es así
pero ahí está atrás toda la conversación
de
entonces es una competencia
entonces si cambiamos la palabra
competir por compartir
porque porque yo soy todos mis dominios
mi familia que me trajo hasta acá que me
enseñó a caminar me enseñó a vivir a
través de familias puede estudiar el
trabajo que me saca el mundo en donde
hay muestro mi valía muestro mis valor
mi coraje
quién soy de más para ampararlos de las
actividades laborales mis amigos mi
grupo de pertenencia
todos mis grupos para nada son todos y
todas esas partes social que es
importante pensar en lo personal
importantísimo para ver quién soy a
dónde voy todo eso y finalmente estamos
acá para compartir la vida con los demás
por lo tanto hace algo por los otros
somos todo eso y todos son igualmente
importantes el punto de ver cómo hacemos
para llevamos adelante
para tratarlos y trabajamos así que
vamos a invitar ahora
le voy a contar con una bolsa para
porque pasa en el día a día esto sigue
pasando las urgencias siguen apareciendo
y los dominios se siguen contando
entonces le voy a contar como hago yo
pero no se lo voy a contar sino que los
invito a ustedes a que el experimento
por lo tanto
les voy a pedir que tome una posición
cómoda
para la vida si es posible
y que si no lo somos
y ahora te voy a pedir
el tomate la música un referente nada
más como referente como para centrar
esta atención te concentres en esa
última crisis de dominio que tuviste
familia trabajo
familia amigos
amigos desarrollo personal etcétera
puede ser importante
y ubica en ese momento para crearlo
en tu mente ahora
y para registrar
esta que pasa en el cuerpo
qué te pasa en la respiración
si ese cuerpo está quieto las
decoraciones
finalmente la mente como escasamente
notaciones de pensamientos
[Música]
sentí
y ahora que estás en ese estado en que
experimentes que vayas a fondo por esa
experiencia sin ningún tipo de juicios
sin ningún tipo de restricción
entregarte a lo que te pasa porque es
utilizar con vos y como vos te tomas las
cosas entonces entregarte esa
experiencia además dejaron de corra de
baja
y ahora muy importante reconocer que es
tuyo
y esto te pertenece porque eres
personalmente a 2
como una inspiración profunda
nunca todas te de pintura
cuando el sabes decir sí
a todos tal como es
y este estado maravilloso de la
aceptación vamos a pasar a la acción es
muy importante
muy importante ya que recuerdo la frase
de todavía dice que si vos hiciera algo
de una forma sistemática y cambiará
radicalmente tu vida
tiene cosas serían
y arias en este momento después de
preguntarme importantísimo en tu vida
en mi caso les comparto es hacerme cargo
de que esta es la forma en que yo me
tomo la vida
ante estas cosas
el recorrido estás
estos cuatro estados donde ahora
agregues una hermosa sonrisa
y te validez internamente
porque eso es lo más gracia
y te pido ahora que lentamente el estado
que estés
vas abriendo los ojos
de vuelvas a este estado
estamos compartiendo
si ustedes juntan todas las letras de lo
que acabamos de hacer
para ver qué dice serás
y la última es sonreír tiene un color es
rojo
y si hablamos de sonrisas
a que nos remitimos
y eso los especialistas a estas mesas
lo que nos llena de alegría con sus
locuras increíbles
los payasos
ah
que hace dos años que hago teatro que
además
y por supuesto aunque denominaría
así que ahora mis colegas klaus que le
van a entregar a todos una actividad que
vamos a hacer
voy a poner mi permiso
cuantos
la verdad que
que se la ponga
bueno
chicos esto es increíble esto es que es
que estar clave es justamente conectarte
con tu emoción conectarte con el fuego
conectarte con el tiempo presente
conectarte con el aquí y ahora que te
corra algo como que corren en este
momento de emoción de alegría de estar
con todos ustedes y eso es lo que me
gustaría que con regístrese en este
momento este pasa ahora con otros
pusiste de análisis porque tu vida no es
lo mismo por nariz de signos
no
entonces le voy a regalar una diferencia
para mañana tiene que estar
les voy a regalar un ejercicio para
mañana
y cuando se levante se ponga la nariz
está que tienen
se mira en el espejo y se toma un
contacto con la mirada
y busquen busquen huellas de su payaso
de ese niño que en algún lado quedó
callado por alguna razón de eso que nos
lleva a jugar ya experiencias increíbles
y cuando lo encuentres cuando encuentres
la huella del día
si no lo que vas a hacer es lo que hasta
yo ahora mismo
es real
después nada virtual
y esa vida virtual va a representar la
nariz real para que vos recorra todo tu
día con tu nariz espacioso
y después cuando termines al día
así es
puedes comprar
pero las calles
bueno el entonces si comparten tu vida y
tu trabajo
con los demás vas a crear relaciones
sanas duraderas y divertidas
del año 2001
yo solo tenía
lista para el trabajo hoy llegó la vida
cómo puedo equilibrando de la mejor
manera posible y cinco niños
y hoy mi corazón late a vemos la vida la
vida como te la tomas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]